Good afternoon everybody. Let's continue
with the agenda. Thank you for joining
this session. My name is Antonio
Rodriguez. I work in Amazon Web Services
and I'm also a developer as many of you
and also a cloud whisperer as I like to
say. We are really just whispering
models these days, not really writing
code. And uh in this session we are
going to be talking about how to take
the applications that you are building
in CL code from prototypes that you
might have in your computer to fully
production ready applications that you
can have in the cloud in this case with
Amazon web services. And uh I think the
story that uh we are telling today is a
story about teamwork, a story about
better together because uh I remember I
joined the team and started working uh
with anthropic more than three years
ago. I remember we were still launching
clot 2 as the big amazing model that was
uh you know changing and shifting the
ground uh below us and u on since then
we have tried to combine the best
frontier models that anthropic has been
developing with the best cloud provider
uh that we had in Amazon web services
and uh this session by the way is a
hands-on session so what we are going to
do is that I'm going to give you a brief
introduction into how do we work
together anthropic and AWS and how you
can use clot in AWS in many different
ways that we have available today and
then we are going to give you some
accounts in AWS so you can free of
charge and with no limitations test clot
in in in bedrock in this case and also
in in general in AWS so you can see uh
how to use it you have a guided
instructions and a workshop and again we
are going to give you an environment so
you can play around with it. So um again
this collaboration started and uh has
been continued as a very long-term
relationship and um we have uh proven
this year by year. Amazon has invested
uh has done a multi-billion investment
in Antropic uh because we really believe
that we are building the future of AI
together and at the same time we are the
primary cloud provider for Antropic and
uh Antropic has uh committed uh more
than 100 billion on usage in AWS as well
in the infrastructure that we are
offering for powering the motors that
you are using every day with cloud and u
an example of the This investment is
project reineer. Project Rineer is
actually uh one of the largest uh AI
compute
infrastructure that was built for
training and hosting the cloud models
that you are using today with entropy.
We are also using uh custom and purpose
built chipsets that are specifically
made for uh the cloud models in the
chipsets that we call Trinium. So we
have a our third generation of Trinium
chipsets already built uh by Amazon. so
that you can actually get the best speed
and also use it in the most cost
effective way uh when you are expending
uh tokens with the with cloud
and uh I think that if we start diving
into the technical part of uh this
collaboration there are three angles
that we basically offer you when you use
cloud through AWS I think the first one
is that you have a very comprehensive
list of features that you can use uh for
let's say a company the model that you
are using. So in bedrock you have a full
platform uh so that you can combine and
fine-tune the models as well. Uh we are
the only provider that allows you to
fine-tune haiku in example in the cloud
and uh we have full integrations with
the rest of the features that we have
available in barog and the AWS ecosystem
in general. The second and very
important point is the security. So we
can make sure that you keep control of
your data at all times. We avoid this
hopping of data going to the public
internet. You can keep everything
private in your AWS boundary. So we make
sure that you uh always align with the
compliance and security uh best
practices that you might have in your
companies or or the regulations. If you
are working in banking or healthcare u
these kind of industries is uh highly
regulated industries. It's very
important uh that you actually have
these options uh for controlling
everything that you're doing with cloud
and uh obviously the data privacy part
uh we work uh nowadays in the latest
generation inference engine that we have
in barrack uh we have zero operator
access uh in the platform which means
that no one from Amazon or from entropic
can actually get access to those
instances. So your data remains fully
private. We are not sharing that data
with anyone. No one is using that data
for training models or anything like
that. So you keep a full restriction and
again this is because we need uh to
align with a lot of compliance
regulations that uh our customers need.
There are hundreds of thousands of
customers who are using these models
every day and therefore it's very
important for us to align on those. Last
but not least, the scalability. The
using those models, cloud models through
bedrock gives you u practically infinite
scalability in the sense that you can uh
really decide how do you want to do the
deployments. You have full flexibility
for choosing regions as well. In
example, you could decide that you want
to deploy cloud only in London region in
AWS or only in the European region. in
example if you have to align with GDPR
and and these kind of regulations.
Now if we see the whole ecosystem who
who is familiar with Amazon bedrock by
the way in this room okay so I was
suspecting less hands to be honest
because uh this is really a clot event
but uh it's great to hear that you are
using bedrock or you know about bedrock
and this and bedrock has been growing a
lot since uh the the beginning since the
last uh three or four years when we
released the service and today apart
from the core which is obviously the
foundation models that you have access
to and obviously uh anthropic cloud
models are a very important point part
of that. You also have other features
that help you in the full journey as a
developer. So you have uh features that
help you doing evaluation that help you
doing pro optimization uh that help you
fine-tuning the models as we mentioned
before or uh doing model distillation as
well if you need it. We also give you
some features that help you connecting
if you have rack use cases. You can have
knowledge bases that are fully managed
so that you can attach to it as well. We
have uh guard rails which is a way in
which you can apply content filters, you
can deny topics uh you can uh protect
PII data or sensitive data by doing
automatic masking and so on. And uh you
can also control hallucinations from the
models by doing uh proper grounding
automated reasoning checks. And uh even
more important in the last uh two years
I would say tools for building with
agentic AI and uh this uh if you are
using cloud agents then awesome but if
you are using the cloud agent SDK and
you are looking for an infrastructure
for hosting your agents in a secure way
in the cloud then you can also use
Amazon bedrock agent core which is uh
again fully compatible with any open
framework that you might be using for
aentic today like chain like crew AI and
obviously cloud agency SDK as well.
Now if I have to summarize in a single
slide everything that I'm saying so far
on the why the better together story why
is it better to uh use cloud in AWS I
would say this is probably the slide
right so first of all as I mentioned the
data that you can get when you are using
cloud in AWS you have a full control of
the environment that you are setting up
and where you are using it you also have
centralized billing from AWS so you can
actually have a single build. If your
companies are already using AWS or you
are using AWS for other things, you can
have a consolidated a single build that
is actually having the usage of cloud
included with everything else that you
might be doing today. You have full
observability through our services like
cloudatch or cloud trail as well in
which you can actually see details on
metrics logs you can see the traces of
everything that has happened and uh we
also offer SLAs so we make sure that you
have a guarantee availability on the
services so you have an uptime that is
uh secure for your applications and you
can go uh safe to production and make
sure that you can scale at the at the
cloud scale uh safely ly um another very
important point is that we have built-in
O integration. So if you are using
single sign on or if you are doing open
authorization o or if you are using AM
roles in AWS in example um you can
directly integrate that with your
identity provider. You could be using
Microsoft enter ID, you could be using
octa, you could be using any of those uh
identity providers today. And that is a
built-in integration that you can do
also for using cloud in bedro. And uh
last point, you can use private link
which means that all the communication
can remain fully private. So you make
sure that no data is being sent to the
public internet at any point. uh when
you are using cloud in bad reg
as I mentioned I mentioned about
compliance before these are some of the
compliance regulations that we u support
and we are uh good for you to use as
well like in example fetram HIPPA and so
on and so forth there is a full list
online if you want to check it out and
uh and more information about all of
these topics
now the good news is that today you have
three ways of using cloud in AWS And
actually this is a the the most options
that you are going to find in the whole
industry right now with first one is you
can use cloth models directly through
Amazon bedrock as I mentioned before. So
basically everything that I was saying
so far in which you have the same uh
high coetus experience that you might be
getting uh directly but in this case uh
fully through the Amazon bedrock uh APIs
that are offered to you. We have
recently added oppos 4.7 and included
the messages API as well so that you can
directly invoke with the messages API if
that's a method that you prefer. Now we
have also recently launched cloud
platform in on AWS. Cloud platform on
AWS is actually generally available
since a few days ago and this allows you
to have the same exact experience that
you might be using today directly with
Antropic but in this case with a
consolidated billing through AWS and
having the access control fully done on
AWS as well. We act as a gateway in this
case and we send all the inference
requests to entropic so that they can
process the request for you. So it's
giving you the best of both worlds. So
you get again the security, the billing,
the consolidated access control that we
are giving in AWS and at the same time
you have all the feature parity with
Antropic including everything that we
have been hearing in this event and the
latest features that you might be using
today including web search files agents
and so on and so forth. Now the third uh
way in which you can use it is also if
you are not using programmatically cloud
but you are rather using cloud desktop.
So you might be using co-work, you might
be using uh cloud code through the cloud
desktop application. You can also use it
directly from AWS. And again you can pay
in a consolidated bill in AWS. Uh and
that you have two ways of uh doing that
as well. One is through the cloud
enterprise in in the AWS marketplace in
which you pretty much subscribe to the
number of developers that you have using
this application as well. But you now
also have the option of using it uh and
and let's say point directly the coord
3P which is one of the latest additions
also that the anthropic team did for uh
connecting cloud desktop to third
parties. In this case you can connect
cloud desktop to bedrock or you can
connect even cloud desktop to the cloud
platform on AWS if you prefer to do so.
So again, you have all sort of
combinations to make your life easier
and uh pretty much meet you where you
are on your needs on this.
Perfect. Let's dive into the actual
workshop that we are going to be
building together. Um I just want to uh
make a recap that first of all you need
two prerequisites for running this
workshop. One is you need an AWS
account. So that's we got you covered.
We are going to give you again a
workshop account that has uh an
environment that you can play around
with and uh you can pretty much be uh
free of charge free of any concern of
using that environment and then the
other thing is that you obviously need
to have cloud code installed uh as an
application and uh we have a few options
for you. So if uh the fox on the back
help me switching to my laptop I can
show you what is exactly what we are
doing. Um you are going to find that in
the accounts that we are setting up for
you. We are having the workshop that is
called introduction to cloud code on AWS
and uh this workshop has some
instructions to how to set up everything
that we are doing. We are pretty much uh
playing around with the scaly draw uh
tool with the repository of the scaly
draw. So you can see how cloud code can
help you playing around with a scaly
draw and drawing architecture diagrams
for you. An example um this is a basic
workshop is if you are already an
advanced user who who is a getting
started with cloud code in this room all
right who would say that is a ninja in
cloud code so you are you have all the
skills on cloud code who is in the
middle all right
who's not answering so u yeah I guess
most of the room is probably on the
middle so you will find that probably
module one is basic for you So it's a
just using cloud code on AWS and
learning how to set it up and uh point
to scalro and so on. Uh module two and
module three are probably more
interesting for you. We are going to
start uh playing with the context. We
are going to start using playright MCP
so we can actually uh take a screenshots
of the diagram that we are drawing and
uh making uh modific automated
modifications through cloud code on it.
We are also playing around with the uh
git workflows and on cloud code and so
on. And in the module three we are going
to play with sub aents and plugins and
we are also creating custom skills hooks
and some advanced uh parameters for
configuration.
I just want to mention that we have an
even more advanced workshop that is also
available for you if you look for this
URL and u basically there you have other
things that are very interesting for
teams who wants to move to production in
a safe way. So here you can learn how to
set up u team standards how to implement
and and distribute uh advanced workflows
as well how to do a scalability cost
control and so on. So in example you
could see um how to set up dashboards
like this one for making sure that you
can control all the use that you are
doing of uh cloud code tokens uh in your
accounts and so on and so forth.
Developer productivity measurements uh
measuring return of investment of your
applications and so on. And last you
have also options for using uh the cloud
agent SDK on the Amazon BRO agent
course. So you can learn how to build
the agents connected to the cloud
infrastructure uh that we have uh here
in in AWS as well. We're coming back to
our workshop again. Uh you have
different ways of uh doing it. You will
see that at the very beginning you will
uh see a screen that looks like this
with some terms and conditions. I just
want to remind everybody that those are
workshop accounts. It's uh individual
for you but make sure that you don't
upload confidential information,
personal information or anything like
that. You will have to agree to the
terms and conditions and click on the
join event. And from that point on uh
you are going to see pretty much this
experience that you have in the
instructions here where you actually
going to have a an environment fully
deployed for you. And uh you will see a
URL here that will take you to a
terminal and a pretty much a visual
studio code UI where you can actually
work on all the instructions that we are
doing in the workshop.
Let's say that you don't want to follow
this path and you want to do it in your
own machine. Then you can do it. You can
use cloud directly in a terminal. If you
prefer, you can configure it for
pointing to bedrock uh with instructions
that we are giving you in the workshop.
Let's say that you want to use co-work
uh or or the cloud desktop app. Uh you
can do it as well. Again, here I'm
pointing to my bedrock account. So I
have a cloud desktop pointing to bedrock
and uh here I'm doing the scaly draw uh
application and the and the workshop
that we have for you uh over there as
well. And uh there is more information
at the end. We are going to be sharing
with you uh more on a guidance in
example for how to use cloud code and
co-work on Amazon BRO. There is a full
blog from my colleagues uh who is
covering all of this in detail and so on
and so forth.
All right, let's go back to the slides.
Uh, please on the back. Thank you.
Perfect. So, um, the instructions for
accessing the accounts are very easy.
All you have to do is go to
join.workshop.awws
and you have to input that access code
that you see on the screen. I think my
colleagues uh have been around over
there. You have the two uh solutions
architects from AWS who can help you
with questions. If you have any
questions, just raise your hand and we
can get uh close and we can help you
out. We also have been handing over some
uh pieces of paper that has this
information so that you can get it uh
easier for copy and pasting in in your
uh laptops. Um one last comment uh with
regards to advanced configurations. If
you want to use uh things like in
example uh uh configuring the settings
that you are using in cloud code
manually um this is the kind of
parameters that you will need to set up.
You might take a picture now if you
want. So the here is how to set up uh
the region point it to bedrock choose
the default model and so on and so
forth. And then on the right hand side
you also have uh some parameters for
reducing the token usage or doing rate
limiting and uh how to enable auto
reporting for telemetry and uh things
like that. You also have some
information here about uh uh how to
configure extensions in the case that
you're using visual studio. Uh but again
it is all about asking clot to configure
itself or you can do it manually if you
prefer through the extensions that we
have there. It helps you with some
things like an example disable the login
prompt that is uh a bit annoying every
time that you start or things like uh uh
hiding the onboarding uh message that
you always get in cloud code and so on
and so forth.